[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález la historia
política de eeuu comienza un nuevo
capítulo un nuevo gobierno 4 años que
estará liderado por el demócrata joe
biden y su vicepresidenta kamala harris
que llegaron a la casa blanca con un
ambicioso plan de trabajo en el marco de
una coyuntura en un país marcado por la
polarización la pandemia del cob y 19 la
necesidad de impulsar la economía del
país y también la reposición o
reposicionar a eeuu en la escena
internacional al menos así lo han dicho
ellos en el siguiente reportaje les
contamos más detalles de los retos que
tiene la administración byd en harris
job aiden tiene una larga lista de
desafíos pero el más urgente es la
pandemia y es que el demócrata toma las
riendas del país más afectado por el
commit 19 a nivel mundial pero hayden se
muestra decidido a revertir la crisis
sanitaria más grave en más de un siglo
necesitaremos más ayuda para distribuir
por completo la vacuna vamos a necesitar
más tests para poder reabrir nuestras
escuelas necesitamos mayor financiación
para ayudar a los bomberos ya la policía
el programa de vacunación ya ha puesto
en marcha debería jugar a su favor para
mantener los contagios a la baja y
ayudar a la recuperación económica otro
enorme desafío para la nueva
administración la crisis económica
creada por la pandemia propició en el
segundo trimestre de 2020 la contracción
más fuerte desde el inicio de los
registros oficiales en 1947 en materia
social
by then se enfrenta a un país que exige
cambios sustanciales la muerte del
ciudadano georges floyd como
consecuencia del uso desmedido de la
fuerza policial propició un enorme
movimiento de protesta que exige el fin
del racismo sistémico el demócrata ha
prometido abordar el tema de la
discriminación
y crear la administración más diversa de
la historia de eeuu ya hay más
afroamericanos en nuestro gabinete que
en ningún otro anteriormente el gabinete
de bailén harris será histórico un
gabinete que se parece a eeuu box que
merck por si fuera poco byd en gobernar
a un país profundamente polarizado y con
una fuerte influencia de donald trump en
parte de la población sin embargo el
nuevo mandatario ha afirmado varias
veces que gobernará tanto para los que
lo apoyaron como para los que votaron en
su contra y ha llamado a demócratas y
republicanos a trabajar juntos para
evitar perjudicar los asuntos internos
para analizar este tema hemos invitado
al programa a agustina giraudi ella es
profesora de ciencia política en la
american university se conecta a esta
hora desde la ciudad de washington la
capital de eeuu también está con
nosotros roberto mateos él es analista
internacional y asesor sobre política
exterior de eeuu es doctor en historia
de américa latina de la universidad de
nueva york él se encuentra en la zona de
brooklyn allí en la ciudad de nueva york
él les recuerdo que ustedes también
hacen parte de esta conversación pueden
dejar sus preguntas también los
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales se la recuerdo estamos en
facebook y también no se encuentran en
instagram y en twitter como france24
y arroba sant y luego la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 pues ya tenemos
el contexto y tenemos a los invitados y
quiero comenzar con agustina
preguntándole por la lectura que hace
usted sobre el significado del inicio
del gobierno de joe biden y de la
vicepresidenta kamala harris
buenas noches gracias por la invitación
creo que es un día de mucho alivio y de
mucha esperanza esto es lo que hemos en
muchos medios de comunicación y lo que
se ve también acá cuando una sola ciudad
de huacho internacional en washington
también es una vuelta a la normalidad
lenta después de dos semanas muy
intensas de mucha seguridad
y de mucha [__] también
creo lo que más rescato del mensaje
inaugural del presidente
bayern es primero el mensaje de unidad
que ahí tengo mis resquemores porque
digamos unir un país tan dividido va a
estar complicado siento en ese sentido
que por ahí ese mensaje es un poco naif
pero sí quiero destacar el mensaje que
me extendió al pueblo americano para
tratar de
y ser un poco más empático con lo que
está sucediendo el mensaje de
transparencia que también enfatizó
de no mentir más de tratar con decencia
tanto a los opositores políticos como a
los aliados como tratar de volver a lo
que era eeuu antes de la presidencia de
donald trump y necesitaba me parece que
es un mensaje realmente muy constructivo
muy esperanzador muy de volver a rehacer
la democracia que sufre tanto en estos
pasados doctor robert matthews allí en
la ciudad de nueva york cuál es su
lectura del inicio de este nuevo
gobierno de este cuatrenio de jobvite
el evento en washington el 20 de enero
fue absolutamente perfectamente manejado
y también es una muestra de cómo cómo
fue la campaña que fue dirigido muy
digamos magistralmente por los
demócratas en no hacer errores y no caer
en las trampas que le hicieron a trump y
los republicanos y él salió como una
figura de bastante ecuanimidad
tranquilidad y
y toda la cara de esta lista esto para
mí en el 20 fue el colmo de la campaña y
lo hizo muy bien no con un discurso
elocuente para todos los tiempos
incluyendo las fases famosas de kennedy
en su inaugural en el año 60
no teníamos esas cosas para para poner
en los guías de historia pero fue un un
discurso realmente muy muy de baile
es decir franco sincero
realmente me importa en el corazón y
también prometiendo lo que dijo mi
compañera
agustina prometiendo decencia
por fin algo decente que ha anhelado
anhelaba el país durante los últimos
cuatro años
agustín adentramos en materia en estos
en este plan ambicioso plan para estos
primeros 100 días también todas estas
reformas ejecutivas que ha propuesto ya
la administración by the end en
solamente un día un poco más de 24 horas
de trabajo y hay una ambiciosa reforma
migratoria un plan llamado camino a la
ciudadanía que beneficiaría a casi 11
millones de inmigrantes muchos de ellos
latinoamericanos 23 por ciento de la
población extranjera que está recibiendo
en eeuu es muy ambicioso este plan como
se lee esto llena de mucha expectativa
en países sobre todo en centroamérica y
también en otros países asiáticos por
ejemplo
en primer lugar destacar quizás como
enseguida miriam asumió la presidencia
empezó a deshacer todas las políticas
realmente muy discriminatorias en
materia de inmigración que había puesto
en efecto
y eso parece un mensaje importantísimo
nos tenemos que olvidar que estos son
decretos no tienen la misma fuerza que
una ley promulgada por el congreso con
lo cual si bien es una buena señal buen
indicador de que la política migratoria
puede ser
desde esta perspectiva mucho más
amistosa me parece que no nos tenemos
que olvidar de que muchas de estas
cuestiones se van a debatir también en
el congreso y en el congreso si bien los
demócratas tienen una mayoría esa
mayoría en el senado está muy empatado
por lo cual me parece que es una muy
buena señal pero todos sabemos que en
materia migratoria las cosas después
complican sobre todo porque los
republicanos tienen una postura mucho
más fuerte e inflexible
sobre este tema y parece que las
negociaciones más complicadas yo creo
que muchas de las políticas que vamos a
ver en los próximos dos años porque no
nos olvidemos que las próximas
elecciones son en el 2022 no en el 2024
los demócratas pueden perder la mayoría
en el congreso en estos próximos dos
años vamos a ver
una agenda legislativa
y realmente para jugarse todo y tratar
de pasar las iniciativas más importantes
como la de inmigración
para empezar todavía no podemos doctor
matthew que tan urgente es esta reforma
migratoria en eeuu y le hago la pregunta
por qué gobiernos anteriores han
intentado presentar planes algunos no
tan ambiciosos como éste que están
presentando en el 2020 pero en el 2013
hubo un plan presentado por la
administración de barack obama y
precisamente en esa aprobación en el
senado pues no no trascendió no fue
votada y no fue aprobada y no se
promulgó como ley y no es el primer
intento eeuu ya ha tenido que encargarse
entre diferentes propuestas de leyes
migratorias pero no funcionan no pasan
si hay que recordar que durante la época
de obama el de portaba la mayor el mayor
número de personas mayormente latinos
antes de trump
o sea todavía estaba luchando entre la
cuestión de quién va a quedar en el país
y una reforma migratoria que no resultó
al final yo creo que estamos en cuatro
años mucho más cerca un reconocimiento
de la gravedad del problema de necesidad
de tener una reforma realmente seria
profunda en la política inmigratoria de
eeuu migratoria de washington y hay hay
razones económicas para resolverlo hay
razones económicas para américa latina
obviamente para por lo menos llegar a un
acuerdo donde las personas que vienen
aquí son aceptada están aceptados
y también es eso es un factor muchas
veces no reconocido directamente cuando
habla de la política migratoria que es
una una cuestión muy
muy del día del día de los últimos dos
décadas política es una cuestión
política que en gran parte impulsó los
populistas derechistas detrás de trump
así que es importante es candente como
tema para los demócratas para resolver
en cuanto a su política y como ha
mencionado a cocinar las elecciones que
vienen en 2022 y entre paréntesis que
históricamente y tradicionalmente
pierdan escaños el partido que ha ganado
la presidencia desde 1986 ustedes me
corregirán eeuu no hace una aprobación
de una reforma migratoria de manera
sustancial también en ese escenario era
un senado donde los demócratas tenían
una participación alta y esto fue
durante un gobierno republicano desde el
de ronald reagan
dentro de este documento de este plan
migratorio abarca muchísimos campos
llama la atención destinar esos 4 mil
millones de dólares en un espacio de 4
años para ayudar a el salvador a
guatemala y honduras para que hagan
frente a los problemas que internamente
provocan que las personas de estos
países tengan que irse particularmente a
estados unidos a buscar unas mejores
condiciones de vida
cómo recibe esto cómo entender esta
cantidad de dinero cómo se puede recibir
desde centroamérica con todas las
complicaciones que hay allí la
inseguridad de pobreza de desastres
naturales agustina
es importante destacar que es una
diferencia muy grande muy grande en la
política exterior de los republicanos
abordan el problema
migratorio desde una perspectiva más
paliativa es decir tratan en vez de
reprimir
y muros en vez de construir muros
prevenir la migración
de atacar los problemas que son los
factores que hacen que la gente deje su
país con lo cual me parece importante
destacar robert decía es un tema muy
complicado para la política americana
republicana y demócrata lidiar con el
tema migratorio pero hay enfoque es muy
diferente de ser republicano es
represivo el demócrata es paliativo o
preventivo
en cómo se directo de
punto de visto de américa latina bueno
ahí nos metimos ya con la calidad
institucional de los gobiernos en
centroamérica y en la resto de américa
latina si es que esto pasa a ser una
forma de prevenir la migración a los
estados unidos
y me parece que es una apuesta muy
grande de la mini
o bien dar a estos paquetes de dinero a
aparecer en américa latina supongo que
vendrán con
contra indicaciones y hay que ver qué
tipo d
condiciones con el gobierno de eeuu eso
me da un poco de miedo porque sabemos
que las condiciones no siempre son son
las mejores y aparte también abre la
puerta para una forma de software de
intervención a través de mecanismos
financieros en la región
más que las condiciones agustina no son
distintas a las que hemos visto en el
pasado reducir la inseguridad reducir la
corrupción que es un problema ya
prácticamente otra pandemia en la región
de américa latina y garantizar algunas
condiciones sociales es el mismo pedido
que hemos oído a lo largo de los años
para cerrar este tema de la migración
doctor matius algún apunte sobre este
plan específico para centroamérica
pero hay algo especial no entendí la
pregunta para cerrar este tema de
relacionado con migración hay algo
adicional que usted quiera añadir sobre
este tema en particular este plan para
centroamérica son solamente una cavidad
de mi parte sobre la cantidad de dinero
aunque yo creo que debemos deberíamos
hacerlo es importante y puede tener un
efecto positivo pero también no
garantiza y no tengo toda la fe de que
puede resolver el problema porque
estamos no estamos hablando de
simplemente llegar dinero invertir
dinero proveer proporcionar trabajo y
así hacer a la gente de américa latino o
de centroamérica y del caribe sentir que
tiene un futuro económico sino que el
problema como ya bien saben ustedes es
también una cuestión social y de
seguridad y esto no se resuelve tan
fácilmente aún con dinero
y aún con trabajos hay una gran por
ciento un gran porcentaje de estas
personas que están yendo de honduras de
salvador por razones de seguridad
personal de que han sufrido
daños personales
y a su familia y training miedo reducir
este miedo es un para mí un trabajo
mucho más a largo plazo de simplemente
llegar a una cantidad como hicimos en
los años 60 con la alianza para el
progreso doctor matthew y agustina hago
ahora la ronda la inversa sigo con usted
doctor robert matthew si pasó al tema de
la pandemia ya han dado unas primeras
instrucciones para una posible posible
movimiento a nivel ya federal a nivel de
todo el país para enfrentar la pandemia
en eeuu está todavía tiempo vaivén para
hacer frente a esta crisis sanitaria ya
los daños están pues son evidentes la
cantidad de muertos es altísima la
cantidad de contagiados es altísima cuál
es su lectura al respecto
bueno vayan hoy mismo dijo que en el
próximo mes al final de febrero van a
ver 500.000 muertos en este país ya ya
como saben ustedes muy bien estamos en
primer lugar el número de muertos en el
mundo tenemos más muertos que cualquier
otro país y el segundo país brasil tiene
la mitad
sólo tenemos un problema grave que ahora
se se van a enfrentar con mucha más
seriedad por lo que lo que hemos visto
durante la campaña por el mismo símbolo
o el modelo simbólico de bain con su
máscara pero también tenemos retos y
barreras y yo creo que dos barreras son
la herencia de trump de tener un sistema
de distribución que no es del todo
funcionando bien no es fluido no es el
sincronizado coordinado y por ejemplo
entre paréntesis aquí nueva york esta
semana pasada el alcalde de blasio dijo
que es posible que en una semana no
vamos a tener la vacuna yo tuve la
vacuna la semana pasada y bien pero aquí
en nueva york y en todo país llega
llegamos al segundo punto de la barrera
digamos era conquistarlo rápidamente y
es la resistencia de mucha parte de la
población de gran parte de la población
a tomar la vacuna como gran parte de
este movimiento anti anti vacuna si por
razones psicológicas y políticas
agustín a sus opinar al respecto
creo
que la diferencia de coordinación va a
estar muy importante
con una agenda
bronca federal que no estuvo presente
durante todo el año pasado bajo la
administración de donald trump fiesta
para mí es sin quiebre fundamental en un
país federal en donde la autoridad está
tan dispersa están descoordinadas y no
nos olvidemos que eeuu tiene uno de los
sistemas federales que otorga más
autonomía en comparación a otros
sistemas federales que le otorgan más
autonomía a los estados
tener una directiva nacional federal es
realmente muy importante casos exitosos
de países federales que han atacado muy
bien la pandemia sobre todo al principio
con una acción coordinada es el caso de
alemania por ejemplo alemania es un país
también federal como los eeuu pero en
donde la presidenta o primera ministra
se expuso
frente a la pandemia y manda directivas
muy concretas
para mí me parece fundamental destacar y
ya lo vimos gestión hoy en la mañana
el presidente empezó a implementar
directivas muy concretas para
centralizar todo esto
obviamente va a generar conflictos con
los gobernadores yo en mi trabajo
académico estudio la coordinación y he
hecho investigaciones sobre la
coordinación durante la pandemia y lo
que si pueda empezar a ver es algo de
conflicto con algunos gobernadores sobre
todo con aquellos gobernadores que son
más reacios a hacer las iniciativas que
puedan llegar a plantear el presidente
valor me imagino por ejemplo del
gobernador de texas diciéndolo pues acá
lo que dice valga o en montaña también
el gobernador diciendo o planteando este
políticas que sean muy diversas en las
que dicen las que proponen haber pero
más allá de este conflicto me parece que
es un cambio radical de 180 grados el
que vamos a darle un presidente que el
primero toma la pandilla de manera más
seriamente pero en qué
mantener una impronta de coordinación
federal tiempo es muy importante para
cualquier visitante que se muestra está
como un bloque unido de país en
totalidad para hacer frente a la
pandemia
agustina el plan económico también que
ha presentado el presidente de bailén
también es muy ambicioso como ya lo
decíamos la mayoría de sus de sus
propuestas así lo son no descartan
aumentar el gasto público precisamente
para hacer frente a problemas como la la
pandemia para aumentar
también la capacidad de los hospitales y
para adecuar algunos sitios especiales
en las ciudades para este plan masivo de
vacunación que también es una gran
apuesta para él también hay un aumento
en los salarios un posible aumento en
los impuestos si hay un gasto público
aumentado pues entendería uno que lo más
posible es aumentar impuestos y también
invertir en la infraestructura del país
pero con miras a tener una
infraestructura mucho más verde y
amigable con el medio ambiente este tema
de la infraestructura sólo hemos oído a
todos los últimos mandatarios de eeuu y
es poco lo que han hecho al respecto y
la infraestructura eeuu
se ve bastante envejecida comparada con
otros países de primer mundo
agustín a su lectura
y creo que de vuelta es un plan muy
ambicioso me parece también que en este
plan by en lo que ha tratado de hacer es
satisfacer las distintas bases y
facciones del del partido demócrata creo
que toda esta impronta más verde de
reactivar
el mercado de trabajo y trabajos o
fuentes de trabajo que tienen que ver
con una demanda muy profunda por los
sectores más jóvenes del partido los
sectores más liberales que buscan es
afrontar me parece que antes tengo un
poco más de confianza de que esa
infraestructura más de carácter verde
pueda llegar a buen cuarto haciendo una
alusión a lo que hemos planteado gracias
porque el tema de la infraestructura que
nunca llega me parece que acá esta
infraestructura nueva viene disfrazada
de de infraestructura y me parece que
acá hay un
en una base política dentro del partido
demócrata que va realmente empujar estoy
acá pienso obviamente
alexander artist
una de las principales impulsoras del
clan
energía con lo cual me parece si
realmente el proyecto de infraestructura
apunte a ese sector me parece que puede
llegar a mucho mejor el cuerpo de ese
plan enfocado en el medio ambiente va
también enlazado con regresar al acuerdo
de parís un importante acuerdo a nivel
internacional que vuelve y deja eeuu a
la par de países de la unión europea y
de otros países asiáticos doctor robert
matthew su opinión sobre este tema del
plan económico
bueno yo es yo estoy de acuerdo
completamente lo que dijo agustina
simplemente para decir que el plan
económico está totalmente
e involucrado digamos o envuelto en los
otros temas de medio ambiente de
conquistar la el virus
acabar con la pandemia y
destacar la gran desigualdad de este
país que si fuera un país en la unión
europea sería el último el número 28 en
desigualdad todo esto está en un en un
plan y ahora por lo inmediato
de atacar el virus con él con el
estímulo el sistema program
i
la única cosa que te voy a decir es que
en cuanto a los impuestos no vamos a ver
algo muy pronto sobre los impuestos
porque esto el año 21 va a tener el
mismo corte de impuestos que hicieron
los republicanos en 2017
así que no hasta el 22 vamos a tener una
lucha política sobre sobre una nueva
política impositiva y josico
hablando de la política exterior hay una
determinación de esta administración de
reposicionar a eeuu como un gran actor
internacional algo que en estos cuatro
años vimos que se alejó un poco de las
grandes decisiones a nivel mundial hubo
una pelea comercial con china se alejó
de la unión europea los británicos se
quedaron esperando ese acuerdo comercial
que iban a firmar londres y washington
para el reino unido- reemplazar un poco
el mercado de la unión europea
abandonado tras el break city y américa
latina también está allí pero no es una
de las prioridades tal parece haciendo
uno la lectura de lo que
para la política exterior el doctor
matthew sé que esperar en nuestra región
con esta nueva administración con puntos
muy claves ahí cuba venezuela colombia
el gran aliado en sudamérica brasil que
tenía una tendencia política muy
parecida a trump y méxico que es un
actor importante en la parte económica y
migratoria por supuesto
primero tradicionalmente no cambia mucho
la política exterior de un régimen a
otro ahora control va a haber un cambio
algo en ese sentido porque la diferencia
entre trump y su régimen en los últimos
cuatro años ha sido notable entre él y
lo anterior y ahora lo que propone la
baño para enfocar en américa latina yo
no veo grandes cambios hay que reconocer
que por un lado el baile es tiene una
historia de ser muy muy centrista muy
moderado y hasta hasta seguir
la política del momento
el voto por irak por ejemplo él tenía
posiciones en los años 90 bastante
conservadores si traducimos esto a
américa latina podemos ver que
posiblemente en colombia más atención a
derechos humanos que ha habido en los
últimos cuatro años más atenciones y aún
a un esfuerzo de hacer los actores
principales para que respetan los
acuerdos de regla 6 y de paz exactamente
y en venezuela
yo veo menos argumentos y comportamiento
agresivo y más atención a la posibilidad
de negociaciones junto con otros países
como colombia y como noruega y otros
países en europa en cuanto a américa
latina en general yo no veo muchos
cambios no ha habido cambios radicales
desde los años de reagan francamente yo
recuerdo la frase de carlos castañeda
hace años de la africanización
américa latina queriendo decir dejar
américa latina por el abandono y yo no
los veo grandes cambios por por la razón
desde quien quien está en el gobierno
ahora y también por por el hecho de que
américa latina no está en la primera
fila ahora del mar o lenguas
internacionales agustina para el cierre
de su comentario sobre este tema de las
relaciones con américa latina
a mí en esta pregunta me resulta el
medio complicado dar una una respuesta
que pueda estar y factor ya porque me
parece que la región es muy muy diversa
como para hablar de una única política
exterior hacia américa latina tenemos
casos como brasil venezuela méxico que
tienen realidades y conexiones con eeuu
lo que es y por ende aquí quisiera
destacar y esto por ahí es un quiebre
con un poco de lo que hemos visto hasta
ahora y lo que enfatiza va a robar
totalmente de acuerdo no es que ha
habido muchos cambios radicales en
política exterior ver que américa latina
pero sí me parece importante destacar
que está de esto ocurre en el contexto y
una pandemia y creo yo que está pues una
oportunidad muy única para eeuu porque
lo que estamos viendo es que en el caso
de américa latina
los chinos los rusos todos quieren
intervenir a través de provisión
y algunos insumos para la salud y me
parece que eeuu tendría que ahora la
región un poco más desde el punto de
vista geopolítico y ver que tiene otros
competidores que podrían estar usando la
pandemia como una ventaja entonces por
ahí esto a eeuu lo ayuda un poco para
cambiar los incentivos hacia la región
es cierto que américa latina no
actualidad pero la pandemia puede dar
otra serie de incentivos que ahora que
se me está dado que sus competidores
principales china y rusia están muy
activos proveyendo vacunas para toda la
población en américa latina
agustina me quedan pocos minutos usted
cree que se puede hacer un buen consenso
en el senado para que todas estas
propuestas sean votadas y pasen y sean
llevadas a cabo
soy una pregunta complicada destinado
primero tiene que tomar una decisión
acerca del juicio político por ejemplo y
creo yo que muchas de las primeras
decisiones con están de alguna forma
definidas por esa negociación en el
juicio político yo de hecho hoy mitch
mcconnell pidió extender el juicio
político por un par de semanas y supongo
que eso tiene que ver con todas estas
negociaciones que empezarán a ocurrir en
el senado el senado no nos olvidemos que
están 50-50 socialmente cuando cual
realmente va a hacer
un motivo del doctor matthew 30 segundos
habrá consenso será fácil negociar allí
en el senado
el sendero para consensos sería mucho
más fácil quitando el fill booster que
es el
el alemán y la maniobra alimentaria de
requerir 60 por ciento del del senado si
podemos quitar esto yo creo que tenemos
mucho más espacio para ganar una
política llega a latinoamérica o al
mundo pues a ustedes todos nuestros
invitados de esta noche muchas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
debate de france 24 de ustedes también
muchas gracias por haber estado en
sintonía de france 24 siga con nuestra
programación
[Música]